we saw this we saw this game at e3
before we saw it at Gamescom last year
now we saw the biggest boss the Platinum
Games have ever created in scale band
what did you think of this one Mike I
like the scale of it I really didn't
mean that I like to scope of it here
okay there we go uh bought like the boss
they showed look not like a shadow of
the colossus vibe really because it was
a giant enemy crab Mike yeah you just
say that about keeping with you three
bosses I thought it was more interesting
than like I originally thought in my
because I originally struck me as like a
devil may cry you're fighting a bunch of
these smaller enemies right you have a
dragon with you but I kind of like the
idea of I don't know fighting this
gigantic thing with weak points with
your buddies though it looked a little
yeah with the cob involved too it looks
a little more nuanced than I thought the
original trailer was conveying it
messier yeah the dante s character threw
me off I'm still not sure about him no
baby honor yeah I'm not definitely
piqued my interest though more than it
did any fans of this type of game here
sitting on the catch it looks I mean I
definitely got excited seeing the you
know against the scale of in but the
douchebag character is really kind of
making me not want to plating a bit yeah
that's the magic the Dragons all that
looks awesome it's it's kind of that
balance of western and JRPG that makes
me wanna play it i think i'd be more
tempted to get it if by if like three
friends called me and said davis really
good you should pick it up and you join
as a four-man group but playing it solo
and just having all my company just
being that douche bag with his
headphones right is that where was
everyone that guy yeah they look to say
co-op variants of that one dude great i
don't know i don't really love how much
time was spent just like shooting at it
as a bullet sponge right yeah yeah I
don't know sound rude because i know
people the people to work on this i work
very hard the very talented people this
is boring right this was like this is a
slow murder of a large crap what why
would you want to watch them it was it
did know what there was a lot going on
but you're saying for what was going on
it wasn't all that compared
yeah there was there was no threat of
danger there right people hitting and
hitting and hitting something with a
giant Shell you know and eventually they
got through the cracks okay I I wasn't
that impressed the game elsewhere I've
seen other footage of the game it looks
great I just don't think it's pretty
back to call not a lot of substance in
the demo yeah I mean yeah we'll have to
well I wonder who the art you know who
the audience is that's really psyched
about this because so many of the people
that I saw looking at you know just
reacting to it in previous conferences
haven't been hot on it so let us know
what you think in the comments below
it's calming edge 2017 to pc and xbox
one